cari italiani benvenuti nel discorso di
fine anno
volevo parlarvi di alcuni argomenti che
mi stanno tremendamente a cuore un modo
anche per chiudere questo straordinario
2014 un anno fatto di passione risate e
video di merda questo è stato l'anno del
cambiamento
l'anno di mostarda perché io povero e
l'uso di merda credevo di riuscire a
fare quello che mi piacerebbe fare dal
vivo cioè monologhi in video non ha
funzionato
diciamo che i video mi sono piaciuti
tutti quelli che ho fatto ma dal primo
c'è stata una discesa non tanto per
quanto riguarda gli argomenti più che
altro per la cattiveria ma ho io mi ci
sono comunque divertito è questo cari
italioti significa che smetteranno
assolutamente no significa che gli farò
in modo un po diverso ma che cazzo me ne
frega a voi tanto sono io quello che li
dovrà scrivere e ho cercato di alternare
questo format con altri tipi di video
sempre umoristici video come in poche
parole oppure toys sono video che mi
stanno molto a cuore anche le uniche due
recensioni che ho fatto durante l'anno
le tengo sempre qui nel mio cuore
italiano insieme a tutti i vostri
splendidi commenti tipo scud ma non
aveva detto che le mollava le recensioni
morali ne ha fatta classico calore del
web della nostra penisola
ho visto anche molti amici e colleghi
cambiare insieme a me tanta tanta gente
si è convertita al marchettone venendo
profumatamente pagata per fare
pubblicità qualcosa per inserire una
marca da qualche parte e io
personalmente non ci trovo nulla di male
ma lasciatevi
era un piccolo consiglio se proprio
avete deciso di farvi stuprare il culo
almeno non fatelo con un ragazzo
ventenne di brescia belloccio almeno
fatemelo sfondare per bene tipo con
quattro camionisti colombiani questo per
farvi capire che se proprio volete
vendervi almeno fatelo per bene così
come ha fatto il nostro amico sole lui
ha preso una decisione non solo si è
fatto stuprare da quattro camionisti
colombiani ma c'era anche tutto un
convoglio di ferrovieri della valsusa
eppure due minorenni che guardavano
insomma ci ha dato dentro come una
scimmia bonobo ma il web non ci sta
siccome il signor facchinetti e la
signora lucarelli hanno deciso di dire
che in realtà il signor gabriele totti
si è fatto da sé è scoppiato il
finimondo
ed è molto appagante veder finalmente
l'intera community italiana del web in
vita certo si sono uniti per odiare
qualcuno e non per fare qualcosa di
recente insieme ma comunque molti dicono
che ormai il web si avvicina sempre di
più alla televisione come infrastruttura
io direi che assomiglia di più
all'intera italia abbiamo tutte le
tipologie di lavoratori chi si fa il
mazzo e non arriva da nessuna parte che
si fa il mazzo iaculo e riesce ad
arrivare da qualche parte che non fa un
cazzo dalla mattina alla sera e se ne
lamenta e chi invece ha la spintarella
dei [ __ ] visto che stiamo andando
proprio in quella direzione e sai cosa
manca la mafia sì perché non prendere
ogni singola categoria di video di
youtube dal make up alla cucina alle
recensioni di film ai videogiochi e
metterci uno che va a chiedere il pizzo
e che spezza le gambe a chi non riesce a
pagare
poi vedrete che si schiereranno due
gruppi chi riuscirà a infiltrarsi nelle
alte cariche e chi invece cercherà di
superare protestando e verrà caricato
dalla polizia
questo 2015 si prospetta al magnifico e
io grazie a voi popolo italiano sono
riuscito a coronare un piccolo sogno e
da quando avevo 16 anni che ho sempre
voluto fare stand up comedy comicità dal
vivo perché ho notato questo nell'ultimo
periodo le persone di persona sono molto
meglio molto più simpatiche hanno molte
più cose interessanti da dire che dietro
uno schermo del computer a fare video è
questo per davvero e per quanto riguarda
me parlare davanti a una folla che ti
sta ascoltando per davvero e non dietro
uno schermo che fa finta di guardarti
mentre si masturba è molto molto meglio
e mi aiuta a togliere le barriere che ci
sono facendo un libero quindi per quella
prima prova io non posso che dirvi
grazie
grazie a tutto il popolo italiano che mi
ha sostenuto e dico questo perché siamo
in periodo natalizio e mi si scalda
sempre il cuore quando siamo tutti uniti
per questa festività
intorno all'albero a cena con i parenti
che tu stai ad ascoltarli e loro non
hanno neanche mezza cazzo di notizie
interessanti da raccontarti ma parlano
per quattro ore di fila mi rende felice
così come mi rende felice questo canale
io come al solito vi ringrazio per tutto
cari italiani vi lascio al prossimo
video che ci sarà o chi lo sa vi rinnovo
anche gli auguri di buon natale e
insieme vinceremo
yes week end